- À 29 ans, Catherine Fournier
semble en voie de devenir
la plus jeune mairesse
de l'histoire des cinq plus
grandes villes du Québec.
Députée provinciale depuis
cinq ans, à Longueuil,
elle recueille 33 %
des intentions de vote.
Josée Latendresse, qui avait
perdu la mairie par une centaine
de voix seulement en 2017,
arrive deuxième à 10 %.
L'entrepreneur Jean-Marc
Léveillé obtient 6 % et
Jacques Létourneau, ancien
président de la CSN et candidat
pour le parti de la mairesse
sortante, Sylvie Parent,
obtient 4 % seulement.
Attention, toutefois : 44 % des
électeurs sont encore indécis.
ALAIN GIGUÈRE, président, CROP
- Il faudrait vraiment
que tous ces indécis, quand
ils vont se décider, prennent
une décision différente que
ceux qui se sont déjà prononcé
à l'heure actuelle. Donc,
je pense qu'elle a une très
confortable longueur d'avance
RÉMY TRUDEL, professeur, ENAP
- Son taux de notoriété joue
beaucoup sur la crédibilité
et sur l'appui qu'elle reçoit
dans la population.
Et dans ce sens-là, le gros défi
de madame Fournier, c'est
d'avoir un conseil municipal
avec une majorité favorable.
- Sylvie Parent était
minoritaire au conseil
municipal, ce qui rendait les
relations houleuses. 50 % des
répondants se disent néanmoins
satisfaits de son
administration, alors
que 17 % sont insatisfaits.
Quant à leurs enjeux
prioritaires, 29 %
des Longueuillois répondent
que c'est d'abord l'accès
au logement et à la propriété,
alors que 18 % choisissent
plutôt l'environnement.
À Laval, un autre jeune est
en tête. Stéphane Boyer, 33 ans,
avait accompagné Catherine
Fournier lors d'un point
de presse sur le logement,
début octobre. Candidat
pour le Mouvement Lavallois
du maire sortant, Marc Demers,
il arrive en tête avec 14 %
des intentions de vote.
Suivent à égalité à 11%
Michel Trottier du Parti Laval
et Sophie Trottier d'Action
Laval. Les cinq autres candidats
recueillent seulement 2 %
ou moins. Mais le taux d'indécis
atteint un sommet à 56 %.
Connaissez-vous les candidats?
- Euh, non, pas vraiment.
- Allez-vous voter?
- Euh, je pense pas non plus.
- J'ai pas checké encore.
- Allez-vous voter?
- Je réfléchis!
- Ma préférence? Bien, c'est
le Mouvement Lavallois! Ils ont
déjà fait leurs preuves alors.
- 65 % des Lavallois
se disent satisfaits de
leur administration et
8 % seulement sont insatisfaits,
ce qui pourrait favoriser
Stéphane Boyer.
Mais rien n'est joué.
- Avec un taux d'indécision
comme celui-là, un, on peut rien
prédire, et deux, bien,
c'est triste pour la démocratie
municipale. Il y a vraiment
un désintérêt, il me semble,
qui est exprimé là.
- À Laval, 32 % des répondants
pensent que la sécurité doit
être la priorité numéro un.
L'environnement et la mobilité
suivent à 19 %.
Environnement oui, mais
peut-être pas à tout prix.
À la question "Préférez-vous
que votre Ville investisse
dans les routes ou bien dans
les transports alternatifs?",
63 % des Lavallois et
61 % des Longueuillois ont
répondu qu'il fallait
prioriser les routes.
Ici Jean-Sébastien Cloutier,
Radio-Canada, L